and the experience to make us a better
country
and he and kamala are going to be in the
fight not for themselves but for every
single one of us
and we sure can't say that about the
president we've got right now
you know i've said this before i never
thought donald trump
would embrace my vision i
understood he didn't agree with my
policies but i did hope
for the country's sake that he might
show some interest
in the job he might take the job
seriously
he never has he hasn't shown any
interest
in doing the work or helping anybody but
himself and his friends
or treating the presidency as anything
more than a reality show
to give him the attention that he craves
but unfortunately the rest of us have to
live with the consequences
almost 230 000 americans are dead
more than a hundred thousand small
businesses have closed almost 300
300 000 jobs are gone in michigan alone
america just had its single worst week
of new covet cases
and what's his closing argument here we
are the worst week
this week i mean we've been going
through this now for
months the federal government has had an
opportunity to respond
four months and his closing argument
this week
is that the press and people are too
focused on covet
cohen kovacovity's complaining he's he's
jealous of kovitz media coverage
and now he's accusing doctors of
profiting off this pandemic think about
that
he said this just yesterday said doctors
are overblowing it because they're going
to make money off doctors cannot
fathom he does not understand the notion
that somebody
would risk their life to save others
without trying to make a buck
his chief of staff says we're not going
to control the pandemic that's a quote
said it last week we are not going to
control the
pandemic we noticed mr chief of staff we
understand you're not going to control
the pandemic but you know who will
joe biden will when we elected president
of the united states
[Music]
you remember when republicans were
saying let detroit go bankrupt you
remember that
now they might as well be saying let
america get coveted
because that's how they're asking if
trump were focused on covet from the
beginning
cases wouldn't be reaching new record
highs across the country
some of the places he owes rallies have
even seen new spikes
after he leaves town there was just a
study
by stanford university that just came
out
showing thousands of people are likely
to have gotten sick
because of these rallies he's holding
what is his obsession
by the way with crowd size you notice
that
he he's always work this is
the one measure he has of success
he's still worrying about his
inauguration crowd being smaller than
mine
[Applause]
it really bugs him he talked about he's
still talking about that
does he have nothing better to worry
about
did no one come to his birthday party
when he was a kid
was he traumatized
what's with crowds
well you know i've had crowds before
you know have you had quite a few
but but you know when a country's going
through a pandemic that's not what
you're supposed to be worrying about
and that's the difference between joe
biden
and trump right there trump cares about
feeding his ego
joe cares about keeping you and your
family safe
and he's less interested in feeding his
ego with having big crowds
then he is making sure he's not going
around making more and more people sick
that's what you should expect from a
president
you can expect something different from
a reality tv star
but from a president you want them
to put you above
their own ego
look here's the truth michigan this
pandemic would have been challenging for
any president
but this idea that somehow this white
house has done
anything but completely screw this up is
nonsense
canada identified its first case the
same
week that the u.s did right
just a few miles up right it's not close
i may not be pointing north but
canada's pretty close by
our mortality rate in the united states
is two and a half times higher
than canada think about that
if we had the same percentage of folks
dying
in canada as we do here
nearly 90 000 americans
would have died instead of 230
000 americans if we had handled this
pandemic like canada did
a hundred and forty thousand of our
fellow americans
might still be alive today think about
that
think about that
and yet despite that last week when
trump was asked if he'd do anything
different he said not much
really not much can't think of anything
i listen i i understand the president
was was anxious to downplay because he
wanted to get credit for the economy
that he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic he
ignored
but it doesn't work that way the job
doesn't work that way
tweeting at the tv doesn't fix things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better
you gotta have a plan you've got to put
in the work
and along with the experience to get
things done joe biden has concrete plans
and policies that will turn our vision
of a better fairer stronger country
into reality joe's not going to screw up
testing
not going to call scientists idiots he's
not going to host super spreader events
around the country
what joe will do is get this pandemic
under control
with a plan to make testing free and
widely available
to get a vaccine every american costs
free
and make sure our frontline heroes never
have to ask
other countries for the equipment that
they need that's what joe biden will do
joe's plan will guarantee paid sick
leave for workers and parents affected
by the pandemic
he'll make sure the small businesses
in every community not just some
not just big corporations but small
businesses that hold our communities
together
and employ millions of americans can
reopen safely
donald trump likes to claim he built
this economy america created 1.5 million
more jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in his first three years
and that was before he could blame the
pandemic
joe biden and i with the help of a
democratic congress
rescued the auto industry gary peters
was there
he told us to bet on michigan
and we did and manufacturing in michigan
grew by 15
over our last four years
trump promised he'd make michigan the
manufacturing hub of the world again
it's up one percent under his first
four years 15
under obama biden one percent under him
that's michigan right here
we added him the longest streak of job
growth in american history
but the economic damage he inflicted by
botching the pandemic response
means he'll be the only president since
herbert hoover
to actually lose jobs herbert who
that's a long time ago
joe biden and gary peters know that the
key
to a strong economy isn't cutting more
taxes for billionaires
it's lifting up the prospects for
working americans
and joe's got a plan to create one
million new auto related jobs
by accelerating electric vehicle
production
he's got a plan to create 10 million
good clean energy jobs and fight climate
change
and secure environmental justice
something that's relevant
to flint michigan you know something
about that
he'll and he'll pay for his plans by
rolling back
trump's tax cuts for billionaires
[Music]
and this is important joe sees this
moment
not to get back to where we were
but to build on the progress we made
together and finally make
long overdue changes so that our economy
actually makes life a little easier for
everybody
for the waitress trying to raise a kid
on her own
for the student figuring out how to pay
for next semester's classes
or the shift worker always on the edge
of getting laid off
or the cancer survivor who's worried
that her pre-existing conditions
protections will be taken away let's
talk about healthcare for a second
let's talk about healthcare for a second
republicans love to say right before an
election
that they'll protect your pre-existing
conditions that's what they say
well you know what joe and i actually
protected them
10 years ago with the affordable care
act
[Music]
and since we did so
with no help from republicans no votes
from republicans
republicans have tried to repeal or
undermine the aca more than 60 times
60 times they've tried to take people's
health care away
and when asked why why are you doing
that why are you being so mean
you don't think these people should have
health care to say no no no
we've got a new plan it's going to be
beautiful it's going to be terrific
except it's been 10 years now and they
still don't have a plan
[Music]
they're trying to bamboozle you
they instead of actually coming up with
a plan they've attacked the aca
at every turn they've driven up costs
they've driven up the number of
uninsured now they're trying to get the
supreme court
to take your health care away in the
middle of a pandemic
in the mid right at the time when people
need health care
they they they've signed on to a case
right now in the supreme court
where they're trying to take insurance
away from folks who need it
with nothing but empty promises to take
its place
and now mitch mcconnell is pouring
millions of outside super pac dollars
into michigan to try to beat gary peters
because that's part of their agenda
michigan here is the truth
joel and kamala and gary will protect
your health care
they will expand medicare they will make
insurance more affordable
for everybody and the reason you know
that's true is because they were there
when we did it the first time
[Music]
and here's another thing with joe and
kamal at the helm
this is a big benefit michelle and i
were talking about this over dinner the
other day
you're not going to have to think about
them every day
you're not gonna have to argue with
your family about them every day it
won't be so exhausting
you'll be able to get on with your lives
knowing that the president
is not going to suggest we inject bleach
as a possible cure of covenant
you won't have to find out
you won't you you won't wake up in the
morning and kind of open your phone oh
news flash uh the president retweeted
conspiracy theories that the navy seals
didn't
actually kill bin laden
you're not going to have a president who
goes out of his way to insult people
just because they don't support him
this is not normal behavior people
we would not tolerate it from a teacher
or a coach or a co-worker or a family
member
if if a neighbor was acting like this
you'd stay away from that neighbor
why would we accept it from the
president of the united states
[Music]
and you know what there are consequences
to this action
there are consequences to his actions
it's not just a joke
it's not funny those actions embolden
other people
to be mean and deficit
and racist
and a phrase at the fabric of all of our
lives and it affects
how our children see the world and how
they treat each other
it affects the way our families get
along it affects the way the world sees
america
that's why joe talks about the soul of
america
that's why he he talks about decency
and kindness and responsibility and hard
work
that more than anything is what
separates joe biden from his opponent he
actually cares about every american
he does not have a mean-spirited bone in
his body
i have seen him spend
spend time with with people that
strangers that he doesn't know when he
hears about
they're going through a hardship he
talks about what he's gone through
when he sees a kid his eyes light up
because because he thinks about his own
kids and grandkids
joe biden tries to live the values we
cherish
honesty hard work kindness humility
responsibility helping somebody else out
that used to be the definition of
manliness
not strutting and showing off
acting important bullying people
used to be being a man meant taking care
of your
other people not going around bragging
but but just doing the work
not looking for credit
trying to live right passing on
those values to your kids
looking out for a community carrying
your weight
giving up a little bit of what what you
might have to help somebody who has
a real need
when you elect joe that's what you'll
see reflected from the white house
and those shouldn't be republican or
democratic values they didn't used to be
they're what we grew up learning from
our parents and from our grandparents
and they're the values we still try to
teach our kids and they're not white or
black or hispanic or asian or native
american values they're american values
and we've got to reclaim them right now
but to reclaim them we're gonna have to
turn on like never before
[Music]
if we're gonna reclaim those values we
need to leave no doubt
we can't afford to be complacent not
this time
not in this election
we got a little complacent the last
election
[Music]
listen i understand why americans get
frustrated and sometimes think
government's not going to make a
difference voting is not going to make a
difference
i understand that government's not
perfect the people in government are not
perfect even when it's working
government's not going to solve every
problem
but we can make things better
a president can't by himself solve every
challenge facing
the economy here in flint or michigan
but if we elect people like gary peters
and dan kildy and we get a house and a
senate
joined with a white house that are more
focused on working people
and getting you the help that you need
they will make a difference
and some folks will get jobs that
wouldn't otherwise have jobs
and some folks will have health care
that wouldn't otherwise have health care
[Music]
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias in our criminal justice
system
but if we elect district attorneys
and states attorneys and sheriffs
focused on equality
and justice and we once again have a
justice department
and a civil rights division in the
justice department that cares about
these issues
we can make things better and that's
what voting's about
not making things perfect but making
things better
it puts us on a track so that
generations from now we can look back
and say
you know what right about then things
start getting better again
the fact that you don't get 100 of what
you want right away
that's not a good reason to vote you
just got to keep at it
you know typically just over 50 of us
vote
who are eligible think about that almost
half of the people in most elections who
are eligible to vote
vote imagine a 60 percent of us vote
imagine if 70 of us vote
imagine january 20th when we swear in a
president and vice president
who's got a plan to get us out of this
mess who care about
folks like you who've been in your shoes
who know what it's like to struggle who
know what it's like to have to work hard
who are thinking about working americans
and have a plan to help you start
getting ahead
what it's gonna be like to have a
president and a vice president who
believe in science
and who have a plan to protect this
planet for our children
and who believe in racial equality and
are sending a
clear signal that we're all in this
together
and are doing the work to bring us
closer
so that we have an america where no
matter what we look like where we come
from who we love
or how much money we've got we we can
make it
and we have a place and we're treated
with dignity and respect
michigan that's what's possible
and i'm asking you to remember
that it's possible i want you to
remember what this country can be
but you can't just imagine a better
future you can't just wish for it
you've got to fight for it you got to
fight for it we got to out hustle the
other side
like never before right here in michigan
and all across the country
we've got to leave no doubt about who we
are
and what this country stands for and if
we do
we will send gary peters back to the
senate
and we will elect a man who loves this
country
and who cares about you and who will
fight
for every single one of us
and we'll look out not just for folks
who support them but even the folks who
don't
my friend the next president
of the united states of america
joe biden
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you trying to
remind you
how good it can't be listened to him
doesn't it
as my mother is saying about barack god
will love him he's a good man
folks it's good to be back with friends
mary nilly governor whitmer lieutenant
governor gilchrist
debbie stabbing out my good buddy gary
peters who you are going to send back to
the united states senate
because i'm going to need him we can
always count on him
to be your senator for you and your
family
and my good friend congressman dan
kildee we need to send back the house
dan's a good man
a good man of course i wish we could
figure out
how to send back a guy who uh
we used to have an expression in the up
in scranton
we'd say when someone wasn't somebody
else's equals they wasn't a patch on his
jeans
i tell you what mr president you're
still driving him crazy because he knows
he wasn't a patch on your jeans
i'll tell you what barack obama
it's great to be with the president
again
it reminds me of what we can be when you
have a president of character
a president respected around the world a
president
our kids looked up to and did look up to
i want to say something we don't say
often enough and i mean this from the
bottom of my heart
barack obama was a great president of
the united states of america
i want to make sure we say it here today
mr president thank you thank you thank
you
went through eight years without one
single trace of scandal not one
single trace of scandal it's gonna be
nice to return to that
flint three days
three days we can put an end to this
presidency we have now
that has divided the nation three days
we can put an end to a presidency
that has failed to protect this nation
three days
we can put an end to this presidency
that has fanned
the flames of hate all across this
nation
and made us a stock around the world
millions of americans have already voted
millions more are voting today
tomorrow and god willing all the way
through to the close of the polls on
tuesday
and my message you are simple the power
to change the country
is not figured it is literally in your
hands
i don't care how hard donald trump tries
there's nothing let me say it again
there's nothing
that he can do to stop the people of
this nation from voting in overwhelming
numbers
and taking back this democracy
[Applause]
and when americans vote no matter how
many threats he makes
america will be heard when america's
heard
i believe the message is going to be
loud and it's going to be clear
it's time for donald trump to pack his
bags and go
[Applause]
[Music]
we're done with the chaos the tweets
the anger the hate the failure
we refuse to take any responsibility
we've got a lot of work to do got a lot
of work to do
and if i'm elected your president we're
going to do it
we're going to act we're going to need
your help in doing it as well
we're going to act to get covered under
control on day one of my presidency i'll
put in action
a plan i've been taking about talking
about for months already laid out
a national mandate masquerading social
discipline testing tracing
all things as president obama just said
it should have been could have
put in place months and months ago
a plan for full and fair
and free i might add distribution of
therapeutics
and vaccines when we get one imagine
where we'd be
if we had a president of war mask
instead of mocking it
i can tell you this we wouldn't have
nine million confirmed cases of code in
this nation
over 230 000 deaths we wouldn't be
seeing a new record of cases
we're seeing right now 90 000 cases
today yesterday 90 000 new cases
we wouldn't be faith by the way five
hundred thousand in just the past week
this guy tells us it's going away well
things will make it go away if he goes
away
folks
we wouldn't be facing another 200 000
deaths in the next few months
this president knew in january the virus
was deadly
and trying to
prove his image he might have tried to
talk to bob woodr he thought he could
change his mind
but what he did he let it be known
all the way back in january he knew how
dangerous this pandemic was
and he hid it from the american people
he knew it was worse than the flu
but he lied to the american people he
knew it wasn't going to disappear but he
kept telling us
a miracle is coming and yesterday
he had the goal to suggest that american
doctors
people are putting their lives on the
line on the front lines
to save other lives along with nurses
and so many others he suggested
falsely that they're inflating the
number of cover deaths
to make more money what in the hell is
wrong with this man
excuse my language but think about it
it's perverted you may believe it
because he doesn't do anything for
other than for money the people of this
nation have suffered and sacrificed
for nine months none more so than the
doctors on the front lines and
healthcare workers
and this president is questioning their
character their integrity
their commitment to their fellow
americans
it's more of a defensive it's a disgrace
especially coming from a president who
has waved the white flag of surrender
to this virus our frontline health
workers
they've given their all to beat the
virus we have a president who's just
given up
i will never raise the white flag of
surrender
we're going to beat this virus we're
going to get it under control
and the first step to doing that is
beating donald trump
look
[Music]
donald trump keeps telling us what a
great job
he's done as president
oh man well did you know
president obama and i as he pointed out
created more jobs in the last three
years of our administration
than he did in the first three years
before the pandemic
how about this or did you know
donald trump's going to be the first
president in 90 years to go to finish
his term
with fewer jobs under his leadership
than when he started
look that's a lot of presidents that's a
lot of crises
but only donald trump gonna have fewer
jobs at the end of his presidency than
when he started
you see i and barack understands
something
donald trump doesn't wall street didn't
build this country
you did working people built this
country
and unions built the middle class
he's done nothing of wage war on
american labor
i see the uaw sign out there first
outfit ever endorsed me in 19 when i was
a 29 year old kid
god love you look
we have a different view we believe we
should be rewarding
work not wealth in this country
under my plan if you make less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year
you're not going to pay a penny in
additional taxes
but the wealthiest people the biggest
corporations
91 of the fortune 500 companies paid
zero
in federal income tax last year they're
gonna start to pay their fair share
the super wealth are gonna pay the same
rate they played at the beginning of
george bush's administration
and going to start to pay their fair
share
why should a firefighter an educator a
nurse
pay a higher tax rate than someone
making literally a billion dollars
or should you why should you pay more in
taxes
than donald trump
he paid 750 in taxes
the one year we know of he's yet to
release i've released 22 years of my tax
returns
you can go online and look he hasn't
released one
he talks about corruption what is he
hiding
yes 41 million bucks out there
who's he owed to if you notice
he's the only president i know of that a
secret bank account in china
paid 50 times more taxes in beijing
than he's paid in the united states and
this guy talks about corruption
look we're also going to act to protect
health care
trump of the republicans just jammed
through a supreme court nominee
for one overwhelming reason as barack
said
the president said we have been they've
been trying over 50 shots to take out
obamacare destroy the affordable care
act
but they're going to be in court i
believe it's
seven days after the election
win or lose they're going to be in court
if they get their way a hundred million
americans will lose protections for
praises and conditions
including more than four million
michiganders
donald trump thinks health care is a
privilege barack and i think it's a
right
for people who have bad account care
we're not only gonna store obamacare
we're gonna build on we're gonna keep
your private insurance if you like it
and you can choose a medical a
medicare-like public option if you don't
we're going to increase subsidies to
lower your premiums and deductibles
out-of-pocket spending reduce
prescription drug costs by 60 percent
look we're going to make sure you keep
the protections for people with
pre-existing conditions
meanwhile donald trump laid out what
he's going to do in his second term
if he's elected to social security the
actuary
at the social security administration
says
if he gets that plan passed it will
quote
bankrupt social security by 2023
something millions of americans live on
paid for their whole life
well i said back six years ago as
debbie will tell you when i said the
republicans are going to try to
eliminate
medicare everybody said no that's crazy
first thing
paul ryan the republicans in the
congress did
was try to cut billions of dollars
out of medicare these guys mean what
they say
i'm going to protect social security
medicare medicaid
because there's a lifeline for so many
hard-working folks
but folks i have to admit to you
it's kind of personal with me there's
nothing worse that this president has
done
in my view than the way he speaks about
our women and men in uniform and those
who've given their
they call them lives suckers
my son beau was a major in the united
states army
gave up the attorney general's job and
petitioned to be able to go with his
unit to iraq
for one solid year after as a u.s
attorney
being in kosovo i might add i'm
going to be a typical dad he's the only
foreigner
in kosovo that has a 12-foot
memorial dedicated to him the major
highway they built
the bo biden highway because of his
commitment
[Music]
my son came home with a bronze star that
could speak his service but like so many
others
before he passed away but less what
he wasn't a sucker he wasn't a loser or
any of you sir
you're patriots and just like all of
your sons and daughters
your parents your grandparents who serve
the president likes to portray himself i
love this
likes to portray himself as a tough guy
when you're in high school wouldn't you
like to take the shot
anyway it's a different story but anyway
a macho man
but when's the last time you read about
saul heard about
a present united states literally being
laughed at
by world leaders when he spoke of the
united nations
laughed at out loud
when's the last time you saw president
united states
being hopefully mocked by the leaders of
nato
at a nato conference and can you believe
we have a president
who acts like vladimir putin's puppy
who put bounties on the heads of
american soldiers serving in iraq
and trump was too scared to challenge
him talk to him six times never
mentioned it
trump's not strong he's weak he commands
a little respect
on the international stage this is a
president who not only doesn't
understand sacrifice
you don't understand courage physical
courage
it takes to serve in uniform in a war
zone
maybe that's why six generals and
admirals who worked for him
left his administration and said he was
unfit
to command be commander-in-chief when's
the last time any president has had that
happen
tough guy that's why i joined special
operations commander
general stanley mcchrystal that's why
head of the navy seals oversaw the raid
of bin laden admiral bill craven
and 22 other four stars have endorsed me
saying they support me to be their next
commander-in-chief
because like obama and pushing before
him
they never respect him but support them
i've been in and out of war zones as
senator and vice president
over 35 times
i tell you what these folks we have only
one percent
of the country is in the military
we owe them they're the backbone they're
the sin you they're the
heart of who we are that's why
we have to support our military and get
rid of trump
[Music]
folks
you know i want to tell you something
think about this this is a guy
who says there's no such thing as
climate change
he calls it a hoax
i see it as jobs health and safety
the impacts on climate are too often
fall disproportionately
on poor communities and communities of
color we're going to make sure
communities benefit from the hundreds of
billions of federal investment
and infrastructure and climate change
we're going to do as a consequence
of the change in destruction we're going
to create
local jobs to rebuild roads fill
sidewalk cracks install broadband
create spaces to live work and play
safely to modernize infrastructure so
you can
turn on the faucet and clean water comes
out and when that happened in flint
will never happen again anywhere in
america
[Music]
we can and must do this donald trump has
rolled back more than 100 environmental
protection laws
many enacted under barack and me
it also holds polluted i'll call
polluters accountable
with the most ambitious environmental
justice agenda ever
folks we're an actor to live around
racial justice in america
protesting is not burning or looting
violence has cannot be tolerated in a
world but
these protesters is a cry for justice
the names of george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake
will not soon be forgotten they're gonna
inspire a new wave of justice america
america has had their eyes opened up
they're ready
look i believe this country has to come
together i know when i announced
well over a year ago when i said i
wanted to unite the country everybody
said that's naive
that was a long time ago you did it
before biden but you can't do it again
well we can and we must we have no
choice
that's how democracies work i'm running
as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
that's the job of a president it's a
duty to care
duty to care for everyone so please
vote you still have an absentee ballot
get into a drop box as soon as you can
you could also safely vert early until
monday afternoon
or you could vote on election day just
make a plan
help get out the vote as he's heard this
ten times already visit iwillvote.com
mi folks
we have such an incredible opportunity
well god love you thank you very much
but here's the deal guys we've got to
vote up and down the ticket here
i honest to god believe i give you my
word as a biden i honestly god believe
we're in the cusp we're in an inflection
point we have a chance to make such
enormous progress
because the american people have seen
what the other looks like
they've gotten a glimpse of the abyss i
really mean it
they're ready they're ready to change so
much
i'll never forget what president kennedy
said when he promised to send us to the
moon
he used the phrase that has guided me
he said we're doing it because quote
we refuse to postpone well i refuse to
postpone the incredible opportunities
to the united states of america for the
american people
there is nothing beyond our capacity
there is no limit to america's future
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america
itself and that's exactly what donald
trump has been doing
from the beginning of this campaign
gender ethnicity national origin it's
wrong it's un-american that's
not who we are folks
everybody knows who donald trump is
let's keep showing though
who we are
we choose hope over fear we choose unity
or division
we choose science over fiction
and yes we choose truth over lies
[Music]
[Applause]
fellow americans it's time for us to
stand back
and stand up and take back our democracy
we can do this we're so much better than
we've been
we can be where we are at our best the
united
states of america god bless you
all and may god protect our troops thank
you thank you thank you
i'm wondering
then that time i went and said goodbye
guys